the internet has added a new facet to
the art of 21st century war hybrid
warfare involving cyber attacks trolling
and social media disinformation has
proved an effective way of galvanizing
support and even tipping the public mood
a group of ukrainian hackers have been
launching cyber assaults on russian
websites since the 2014 annexation of
crimea but they're not the only ones
using these methods to shape events on
the ground
russia's war against ukraine
the attacks are not only taking place
militarily but also virtually
ukrainian authorities accuse russia of
targeting government and banking
websites as well as deploying malware
aimed at limiting the country's ability
to defend itself at feeding false
information into social media
influencing public opinion and reducing
ukrainians access to information but
ukraine is retaliating here too
shortly after russia invaded ukraine's
minister for digital transformation
endorsed a grassroots group calling
itself the it army
an estimated 290 000 volunteers are
using a dedicated channel on the
messenger service telegram to hit back
at virtual russian attacks we
formed
an i.t army of ukraine so we invited
like
people that who want to help to fight
this russian invasion
on different fronts and uh there was
focus they basically were focused on two
things uh first fight this information
and also take down uh russian
infrastructure a digital infrastructure
because they were attacking us for eight
years so the war with russia started not
couple like a week ago this it started
uh almost eight years ago and they were
instantly attacking us
the i.t army includes members of the
hacktivist collective anonymous the
collective claims that over the past two
weeks it has successfully leaked
information from the russian ministry of
defense database and hacked into russian
state television and streaming services
to show uncensored news of the attacks
on ukraine
cyber attacks are often difficult to
verify however some cyber security
experts are voicing concern
such attacks they say could be
considered an act of war and lead to
further escalation of the conflict
for more on the virtual scale of this
war i'm joined now by joshua tucker he's
the director of nyu's jordan center for
advanced study of russia and an expert
on the relationship between social media
and politics mr tucker thank you so much
for joining us on the day
this war is seemingly unfolding live on
social media how are different actors
using it and how is that impacting
events
uh thanks so much for having me here
today yeah i think this is kind of one
of the things that's most interesting
here is just how quickly information is
able to be transmitted from what's
happening on the ground globally and
that's had a couple of different effects
one effect is that it made the kind of
original
russian disinformation campaign in the
lead up to the election which was based
around uh disinformation around ideas
that ukrainians didn't like their
president that ukrainians would welcome
the russians as liberators that there
were genocide against russia there was
genocide against russians in the eastern
part of the country going on it's kind
of made those narratives sort of
evaporate overnight at least outside of
russia
the second thing that's happening here
is that i think that social media has
kind of been instrumental
in amplifying the effect of the
sanctions
one of the most amazing things we've
seen about these sanctions is that
companies whereas in the past companies
might have tried to skirt sanctions to
be able to sell their products now set
companies are even getting ahead of
sanctions by pulling out of russia and i
think that that's largely being driven
by the realization among western
companies that they're living in a kind
of very different era where social media
allows sentiment around companies and
how they're dealing with big public
political events like was the case in
2020 in the united states around the
social justice movement that that's
become this kind of incredibly sort of
powerful force as well
let's talk about the situation in russia
itself at this point independent media
is effectively banned and access to many
social media platforms has been
restricted by the government in moscow
what kind of information do russians
have access to what are they seeing of
this war
i mean the bottom line is that most
russians if they get their news from
television are seeing the official state
narrative and the official state
narrative runs along a number of
dimensions that this is the fault of the
west that this is a sort of natural
reaction to an entire uh period of nato
expansion going since the end of the
cold war that's been going on for 30
years this overwhelming narrative as i
said before that you know that that
ukrainians didn't like their government
that they were ruled by nazis that this
was actually an attempt at
denotification
these are the narratives that people are
getting on russian television but what's
also happened as you correctly note
since the start of the war has been a
crackdown on what used to be a more open
system for russians to get their news on
the internet uh we've seen the end of
kind of or even on radio we've seen the
crackdown on sort of the last few
remaining independent media voices that
were uh accessible on the internet or on
radio and we've also seen moves to ban
uh outside social media platforms like
facebook and twitter
all of which is designed to make it
harder and harder for russians to get
access to information that's circulating
widely in the rest of the world about
what's actually happening on the ground
in ukraine including the sort of the
setbacks that the russian military is
having fighting this war
but these restrictions must be
noticeable to everyday citizens how is
the censorship being perceived in russia
yeah that's a great question i and i
think on some level we might look at
this and see that if russians suddenly
realize that facebook is taking has been
taken away the twitter's been taken away
that television channels they used to
launch are taken away it might be
something that signals to them that the
war is not going as well uh as putin
might have hoped however it's important
to realize that you know it just as in
in ukraine this has led to a surge in
patriotism we generally tend to see when
countries get involved in foreign
conflict effects what are known as
conflicts what's known as rally around
the flag effects and so i think people
especially in the early days of conflict
are willing to sort of accept a lot what
their government is telling them in
terms of you know the necessity of
sacrificing for the war effort the
importance of the effort for what's
going on for russia however some
narratives are going to get increasingly
hard to sustain uh and that's where you
get into the questions around
particularly the sanctions right which
are going to have real effects are
already having very real effects on
lives of ordinary russians and you also
get into the question of the reality of
the results from the battlefield right
there are russian soldiers who are not
going to be coming home and as those
numbers increase and as the time goes by
that begins to conflict with sort of
official narratives and it becomes
harder for these things to be to be
separated it's also the case that
russians are able to
you know russians are able to access
vpns to try to get information from
outside of russia but that then leads to
the you know the ramping up of
repression to try to prevent people from
doing this
interesting stuff joshua tucker director
of nyu's jordan center for advanced
study of russia thank you so much for
your time
thanks for having me
[Music]
ukraine and poland are calling it
genocide western allies are calling it
the indiscriminate use of weapons a
deadly attack on a maternity hospital in
the besieged city of mario poll has
prompted demands for an international
investigation into possible war crimes
u.s vice president kamala harris has
spoken of atrocities of unimaginable
proportions taking place since the
invasion began
ahmed reports that russia is using
cluster bombs and thermobaric weapons
the war on ukraine appears to be
entering a new level and i want to bring
in now laurence baranza she's the
director of the transatlantic defense
and security program at the center for
european policy analysis and she joins
us now from washington
miss baranza good to see you russia's
attacks seem to be growing more and more
indiscriminate what's the strategy
behind that if there is one
well thanks for having me
i do think the strategy behind this is
uh russia is resorting to its
traditional way of war it's the playbook
that we've seen in georgia in chechnya
in syria which involves this kind of
indiscriminate attacks that we're seeing
applying massive firepower rockets
artillery missiles against major
population centers essentially to try
and rough up the city
enough that it allows russian forces to
move in and to facilitate their
occupation and i do think there is a a
blatant disregard for what they are what
they are targeting with these strikes
and these shellings uh but part of this
is also uh their strategy to try and
break the resistance of the ukrainian
people so i'm not surprised that we're
started starting to see this horrible
humanitarian catastrophe take place
western nations worry that russia might
be planning a false flag operation to
justify the use of non-conventional
weapons what's your take on that
i do think it's a real concern i mean we
saw through the us's strategy of kind of
aggressive declassification of some of
russia's false flag operations before
the initial invasion that this is
clearly in the russian playbook to try
and manipulate the information
environment but i think the ukrainian
people
at least and and now increasingly
western citizens are very much aware of
these types of tactics
and i do think that the russians may
attempt something like this to use to
justify the use of a chemical weapon i
think the use of a tactical nuclear
weapon is considerably lower than that
but you know we've seen we've seen the
use of these weapons in other contexts
and i do think there is a great concern
and that's a possibility here
now while all of this is going on the
two sides met for the first time on the
ministerial level in antalya in turkey i
want to show you a clip of what russia's
foreign minister lavrov said after the
meeting let's listen in and then come
back to you
are we planning to invade other
countries
no we are not
we didn't attack ukraine
as we've explained many times a
situation directly threatening the
security of the russian federation was
created in ukraine
and lawrence barranza is still with us
the russian foreign minister they're
saying we didn't attack ukraine and
we're not planning to invade other
countries the first statement is of
course false we know that what do you
make of the second ukraines and russia's
neighbors especially those without a
nato membership have been holding their
breath for months now
right well i think this underlines that
the kremlin cannot be taken at its word
of course we can't believe anything
we're hearing coming out of the kremlin
and i do worry about the future of
countries that don't have a nato
guarantee i'm thinking about georgia or
at moldova for example you know the
value of being part of the nato alliance
has been made crystal clear by all of
these events and i don't think that that
is a line that putin wants to cross to
invade a nato ally
but i do think you know
other countries that are not part of
that umbrella and have those security
guarantees are at risk now that said i
do think the russians military forces
are facing significant setbacks on the
ground this war is a lot more costly and
time consuming than putin hoped it would
be so i do think in the long run this is
going to drain the kremlin's willingness
or desire for kinetic operations
elsewhere so while we might not see a
conventional invasion uh in the short
term i do think they're going to
continue to up the ante on political
warfare and kind of other types of
hybrid threats
on friday vladimir putin is going to
meet with belarusian president
lukashenko what's his role been in all
of this
well luka shenka is trying to walk a
very delicate line i think uh you know
he likes to pretend that his country has
no role in the in russia's invasion of
ukraine but his decision to dance to
moscow's tune is one of his own at
choosing and
you know he is contradicting himself in
some of the statements claiming that you
know belarusian territory is not being
used for certain strikes uh or to as a
conduit for russia's invasion uh but you
know he while he doesn't want to be
dragged into a full-scale war with
ukraine because i don't think that's in
the populist interest in belarus he also
cannot be seen to be a traitor to
vladimir putin because he
he dug his own grave he's completely
dependent on kremlin's support so both
of those options would be disastrous for
him if if he can't balance these two
now this operation is not going
according to plan for putin you said it
before he's facing tough resistance and
he doesn't have the money or troops to
occupy the country
what do you think could be an off-ramp
for him here
well i think his invasion in the first
place shows that he was never truly
interested in diplomacy so i don't think
that there is any concession that the
west can make to to kind of end this
neatly for putin um clearly there is a
lot of ukrainian resistance and i think
the longer that this goes on as you said
the more difficult it's going to be for
for putin and the kremlin to sustain the
sanctions are starting to squeeze it's
more difficult for him to to be able to
actually hold the territory and even in
the long run i think that
putin will be hard pressed to be able to
operate and build and sustain some of
the critical infrastructure that's being
destroyed we're gonna have to leave it
there i'm really sorry we're running out
of time lawrence miranda thank you so
much for your insights
you